les travaux ne sont pas encore tout à
fait fini mais bientôt ces îlots de
terre deviendront des zones végétalisée
de nouveaux espaces de jeux pour les
élèves mais aussi des terrains où l'eau
de pluie ruisselle plus honte d un père
mobilisent comme ça l'eau s'infiltre en
s'infiltrant on accroît le stockage
d'eau dans le sous sol ce qui lorsqu'on
a des chaleurs permet de ressortir et
donc du fugu de réduire la température
en surface et en complément on
végétalise oublier la grande surface
goudronnée les terrains de sport qui
prennent toute la place désormais dans
la cour de récré de l'école brossolette
tous les revêtements sont perméables et
les différents espaces s'entrecroisent
l'idée c'est d'avoir des ambiances et
des coins différents le coin zen le coin
des touffes ou le coin des to do le coin
où ils peuvent un peu joué au ballon le
coin où ils peuvent jardiner le coin ils
peuvent jouer avec l'eau le coin où ils
peuvent retrouver le sous-sol géologique
donc la cour devient un support
pédagogique en même temps qu'elle est
un gigantesque parc est une zone de jeu
fantastique pour les enfants des
aménagements immédiatement adoptée par
les élèves et l'équipe pédagogique
dans l'école brossolette dans la course
était les garçons qui jouent au foot et
les filles qui tournait autour en
sachant pas trop quoi faire c'est sympa
de rejouer au foot un as outreau nul là
du coup passa réorganise complètement où
on voit les filles et les gars ont joué
ensemble de différents âges en plus à
besançon cette cour d'école est la
première à bénéficier de cette
conversion écologique ça va nous servir
de test on va voir cette année comment
autant les enfants que les enseignants
que les parents que les habitants du
quartier vont s'en emparer et puis
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne qu est-ce qui
fonctionne un peu moi qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait améliorer chaque année cinq
nouvelles cour de récréation devraient
bénéficier de ce type de rénovation pour
un budget annuel d'un million d'euros